are guns more than two-thirds of Roger
crawl's stock are AR-15 style weapons
and parts so who buys them Joe truck
driver it could be a judge a politicians
it can be
you know Harry homeowner it's it's
literally it's a gun for everybody the
best-selling rifle in the U.S is popular
in part because it's powerful has
minimal Kickback and it's extremely
customizable standard Barrel heavy
barrel and variations thereof you can go
to a quad rail handguard this weapon of
War now made for the public has also
become the most divisive gun in America
in Congress Republicans wear its
distinctive outline on their lapels many
Democrats wanted outlawed
so you see this beautiful gun and
American Gun buyers can't get enough of
it there are 20 million in the U.S it
has also become the gun of choice for
Mass Shooters in America it does shoot I
promise it fires three times as fast and
as far as a typical handgun and leaves
massive wounds that make it far more
lethal you're gonna do so much more
damage I think that most people who are
not familiar with being at the scene of
those kinds of shootings
most people would be shocked at how one
rifle round can tear a person's face off
or tear their body apart a national ban
on new sales of assault weapons passed
in 1994 and expired in 2004.
polls show most Americans favor stricter
gun laws but there is a rural and urban
divide here in small town in Rural
America more people favor the most
popular rifle in America
several states in the District of
Columbia have outlawed AR-15 style
weapons in January Illinois became the
latest leaving Roger crawl with a store
full of guns he can't sell in his own
State people are pissed that they can't
come in and buy the stuff they want to
buy and you know what it's America you
know you can should be able to do
whatever you want to do as long as you
don't affect somebody else
whether the AR-15 affects others enough
to ban it is a question likely to
continue to divide Americans for some
time John hendren Al Jazeera
Carpentersville Illinois